I see girls in tears and that's because
of your sign you don't know who Brett
Kavanaugh is this man doesn't know who
Brett Kavanaugh is time for the latest
installment have changed my mind
unedited conversations and controversial
topics with an opportunity to
rationalize one's own position as always
comment which topics you most like to
see in the future below today's topic
you've all heard of rape culture and
rape culture isn't that okay
rape culture on college campuses an
example of rape culture March to end
rape culture that rape culture as it's
taught in academia and described in the
media only it's not real now trigger
warning for those of you particularly
frustrated by entirely anecdotal
evidence in the face of empirical data
this episode may prove uniquely
difficult to watch that's just from
people that I know I know a lot of
people on this campus I'm honestly not
talking about empirical data at all and
I don't think we should look at it I
just here go doubt it but what I'm
saying is I see people walking around I
see girls in tears it's all anecdotal
but I know people on campus that have
been raped in and chosen not to report
it okay you're told you how empirical
data is good it's not possible because I
personally know more than 10 people
anyway you get it so this time before I
even got started people were ready for a
discussion
or that I'm sorry to hear that
I've not been raped
no that wouldn't be that wouldn't be
convincing argument I I'm very sorry no
no I think I think yes yes would you
like to sit down I don't generally
consider myself an idiot [ __ ] but
just for her sake I'll play one on TV
this time I allowed her to assume that I
know nothing so that she could teach me
thank you what a bunch of cameras all
set what's your name Maisie Maisie nice
to meet you mate nice to meet you so you
um just yelled this idiot is on campus
and so do you first III want to we are
obviously aware of what we've done oh
yeah rape culture I guess we need to
define how do you define a rape culture
first I had to find rape culture as a an
area a general area where people think
that they can take advantage of other
people due to certain situations which
sometimes include like places like
college campuses where there's a big
congregate of people drinking and
they're not sure where the level of
consent is okay so would it be fair to
characterize rape culture as something
certainly as it's been I guess sort of
described in academic circles the idea a
societal or a patriarchal society where
rape is either encouraged or it's
tolerated um like what it doesn't have
to be a male that rapes a female like I
don't beat either way but I didn't say
that okay well what's your weapon
well that's the idea break fall to the
idea that the rape is and you sort of
echo that I want to make sure we both
agree to start with that it's a society
or culture at large where rape is either
promoted encouraged or tolerated yeah
okay yeah I don't agree can you tell me
why statistically it doesn't wear out we
we charge rapists we put them in jail
rape is a very rare crime and I don't
believe that we live in a culture that
supports or condones rape or tolerates
it but what about the fact that so many
rapists don't go to jail I know plenty
of people I've reported my rapist he
didn't go to jail many of my friends
have reported their rapists they
go to jail like I actually literally
don't know of people my age anybody
who's gone to jail who has been
apprehended there are boys on this
campus I've been sexually assaulted by a
boy on this campus who walks around and
goes to class every single day so how is
that clear for some apprehension well
there's anecdotal right and then there's
the empirical data so I want to get away
from me speaking for all men or people
who are sort of right-leaning and you
speaking for all women or sort of
advocates of a more progressive
worldview I'm gonna just your phone I
think someone's calling in it it slipped
down there I want to make sure you get a
good shot thank you
you you went from from rape it's
interesting to me to sexual assault yes
first off I think again it's very
important we define the terms there's a
delineation between the two oh we agree
yeah but would you say that like sexual
assault isn't like what part of rape you
know sexual cell is a part of rape but
someone can commit some kind of sexual
assault or sexual harassment and it not
be rape so I don't I'm probably pretty
sure you don't want to get into your
personal experience on camera if you do
we we can but again it goes back to the
question this idea that we support or we
tolerate where we encourage rape or
that's occurring in numbers that are out
of the ordinary but fortunately to other
crimes you know rapists are convicted
about the same right as armed robbers
for example do we have an armed robbery
culture a rape is a horrible terrible
heinous crime and I'm not saying that
like rape culture like I'm honestly not
talking about empirical data at all and
I don't think we should look at it as a
peer code data because first of all like
I don't know if you know how like
uniform crime reports work but that's
like certain things that police don't
report so sometimes those numbers are
skewed first of all and like sorry what
do you mean uniform crimes do you know
like uniform crime reports and how that
works maybe several times going into one
report and no it's like where the police
report to the FBI specific crimes that
occur but they are like sometimes they
don't report everything and that's how
like that's the problem
no sometimes they just don't because
sometimes it looks better on their area
and so statistics can't always tell you
exactly what happens and then there's
other forms of like
methods like the NCVS they interview
victims like one-on-one or there's like
self reporting and that shows that we're
missing a lot of data that the police
just haven't reported to the FBI so I
don't think you can base all of this on
empirical data when well I think we can
but what would you base it on because
you obviously you referred to me as an
idiot that rape culture yeah yeah
I'm basing our you and your male
privilege to so and I think I'm gonna be
on that one yeah I do I do and like my
my brother and I were actually just
talking about you yesterday like yeah
you're really something I'm I don't know
how you ended up back on this campus
because you turned into a meme do you
know that you're a meme yeah on Twitter
yeah so I don't know how you have the
audacity like come back on our campus
and say that rape culture is a myth
because that's personally offensive to a
lot of people I know actually and so
especially like the audacity to come
here and hear and speak the truth true
you know what how about somebody rapes
you and then you come and tell me that
rape culture is amid nothing to do with
what we're talking about and I think
you're told you how empirical data is
full because of you see our crime report
don't agree have you you didn't even
know any UCR crime reported do you even
know what NCVS stands for you tell me
that let's go to statistics okay how
often you believe rape occurs because I
got a rape culture we often see I cannot
tell you the exact number because as
I've said I've repeated to you multiple
times that like you see our crime
reports are simply not accurate and
there are other like methods and it is
proven that those are not accurate we do
not have all of those numbers we don't
have all of those numbers we have quite
a bit we have from the FBI we have them
from the DOJ yeah but do you see our
reports that you didn't know existed let
the record show he didn't know what a
you see our crime report is I learned
that in my intro to criminal justice
rape occurs I don't I truly I couldn't
tell you okay for you to say this
idiotic to not believe that there's a
rape culture again when we both agree I
think there's rape culture you just
don't believe that I think there's an
interrupting culture right
now an interesting culture I'm not for
me you keep interrupting me I said can
you define that for me yeah you keep
interrupting
okay okay go I'll go uh yeah so let me
finish here so for me to be so idiotic
as to not believe in rape culture which
we both agreed is the idea that rape is
perpetuated encouraged or tolerated in a
society you would need to present some
kind of data anything I know you think
empirical that is bolted that's fine
some kind of evidence to support your
premise that rape is tolerated or
encouraged the United States yeah I mean
it is totally I mean have you seen like
Brett Kavanaugh are you familiar with
that situation right now like me you
don't know who Brett Kavanaugh is this
man doesn't know who Brett Kavanaugh is
and he's gonna stay here and tell me
that rape culture is a myth he is
currently Donald Trump is trying to
appoint him to the Supreme Court and the
fact that you don't know that shows me
that you don't actually really know
what's going on in society because that
is a really big deal and that is the
Supreme Court is the highest I don't
know who explained it to me why is that
important to improving a trig function
so he is currently he is under fire for
some sexual assault allegations and that
he like supposedly were not 100% sure
but he allegedly raped women when he was
younger and he in front of a trial was
saying that like they found in trial
this is in front of this is not a trial
but it's in front of Supreme not Supreme
Court justice it's in front of Senate
Senators important people and as they
ask him these questions um they pull out
his yearbook and they find terms like
devil's triangle which if you don't know
what that means that's Oh two males and
a female and that's two males ganging up
on a female it is like you're the first
to rape and so he's out here and that's
who they're trying to a point and this
man is is Brett Kavanaugh Brett
Kavanaugh sir and so the fact that like
somebody this important that is going to
be on the Supreme Court which I'm at
this point I'm unsure of like what you
know about the government but that is
the highest position that you can
acquire and so let's replay the Supreme
Court Supreme Court Justice it's high up
there
it's high up there so um the fact that a
rapist is probably going to be a point P
I investigation but it's a biased one
because it is from the Republican side
which they want him appointed so so I'd
like to get back to Brett Kavanaugh
because it seems like this is a big case
but again that would be an anecdotal an
anecdotal story again how does that
prove the statistic that rape is
encouraging committed at large in the
United States and condoned you're
telling me that like if somebody if they
feed highest the highest the Supreme
Court if we're gonna appoint somebody
who participates in a Devil's Triangle
and refers to it as a devil's triangle
you're telling me that that's not the
standard of what is good and what is
right
so can I answer your question yeah you
can answer me question so if I'm to
answer the question on Brett Kavanaugh
and dr. Christine Ford or any of the
other allegations coming forward from
Michael a Bonetti
who represents actually the other way
you accuse him of gang rape as well
that's separate again from the evidence
it's about one a nineteen hundred women
are raped in United States according the
FBI it's about one in a thousand for
college students if you include all
sexual assault according to the
Department of Justice or Bureau of
Justice about one and 52 of all sex that
includes you know playing grab-ass with
Brett Kavanaugh you know it's
interesting you mentioned a percentage
what evidence has been presented um
please what do you need my place where
did it happen I don't freaking know I
wasn't at high school it was back when
he was in high school like lower a
journal yeah general who it's these um
if you're familiar with miss Ford
she has come forward and then I believe
one or two other women have come forward
and said this book Ford is definitely
the know she brought forward witnesses
all of whom could not cry brighter story
somewhat babe outright refuted it I mean
like this
this woman is willing to she's actually
willing to undergo intense FBI
investigations she has had no resistance
to that but he has actually denied over
and over he keeps saying he doesn't want
it and now they're giving him like a
little special little FBI investigation
I think this is something you see
there's no none of what you've just said
is correct it was work you Bruce mean
anything to you no it doesn't
that you really did you really think
that I didn't know who Brett Kavanaugh
was I really did it honestly at this
point like I'm unsure what you actually
know right yeah the whole reason was I
was I was hoping for you to sit down and
you see now if you go back every single
thing I told you I didn't know because I
wanted you to explain to me you've
explained nothing you presented no
evidence or data the only thing the only
time you've addressed evidence or data
is saying that it's [ __ ] - use your
words and it doesn't matter the amount
of rapes matter the conviction rates
matter what we host rapist matters and
when you come out instead of live in a
rape culture and you compare dr.
Christine Ford's allegations let's say
we have no idea whether they're true or
not zero evidence whatsoever from 35
years ago you can't run an investigation
whether who what when where or why we
have none of it - then use that as a
springboard to say that we live in a
rape culture I think it's intellectually
disingenuous and I think it does a great
disservice to people who have actually
been a victim of a horrible crime yeah
I'm aware because I've been a victim to
that crime and as you say like you
haven't and you know like like you said
you don't even know what a Uniform Crime
Report is and so maybe if you I also
said I didn't have a break and I was so
I mean maybe you do know what that is so
then how can you sit here and tell me
that how can you sit that this is all
like these statistics are all 100%
correct
no I'll let you back on this campus
that's a public sidewalk nobody invited
you here nobody invited em you can we
ask him to leave this campus is this
being handled
[Applause]
proud of it have you ever been raped No
let me ask you this have you ever had
your house under threat under threat 4
with a bomb threat you've had the FBI at
your house have to actually circle your
house and have armed guards so the point
is the point is we all have individual
experiences but that does not change the
fact of the matter that we do not
encourage a rape culture in the United
States rape is a horrible crime here's a
let's use break cabin as an example
because you brought them up look this is
really important first off what happened
to you I have no I I don't know the
story I don't want you to get into
personal details if you're uncomfortable
horrible terrible if that happened I
can't say that it has because I'm not
allowed to oh yeah I probably has it
well no legally I can't accuse a man of
something if he has not been convicted
of a crime let's say I believe you
though I believe you I'm really sure I'm
really sure it happened to you but a
good example with Brett Kavanaugh if
Brett Kavanaugh did all the things that
he accused him of for example a triangle
gang rape gang rape if he raped people
cocked his head back and left I say that
castrate him and give him life but if
it's not true
I feel probably worse for him than any
man I can think of in recent memory the
only difference between the two is
castrate the man versus empathy is the
truth and I think with all of these
arguments with all your decisions you
don't either we're trying to see the
truth like we don't have the truth so
how can you just say that that's a good
question like why is he allowed on our
campus if this isn't even like an
organizer no I am not part of this yeah
you know but if he's gonna sit here and
say the rape cultures admit that
somebody needs to sit here and say we're
gonna deal with that but you're not
helping the situation
which so you we can continue the
conversation you like or anyone else
will move forward I actually have class
to get to exist and you're telling me
one in a thousand I can tell you that's
bull what a 19-15 1,900 and in here I
can guarantee you multiple people right
have been raped and this is not nineteen
hundred people so ok how can you
guarantee that myself to this man and
this man is saying one in 1900 1900
accordion be I wanted nineteen hundred
people have been raped I can guarantee
that I'm not the only one standing here
that's been raped and weird that 1900 so
thank you and thank you and I hope you
get that hell off our campus
[Music]
which I'm certain back I'm Nick Nick
nice Michael I gotta say I kind of liked
your podcast I'm on the other side but
okay I like watching everybody well yeah
so yeah I don't I don't know how
familiar are with this but it seems like
you disagree with the position that rape
culture again is just defined in
academia with gender studies and
feminism and has only discussed in
societal nomenclature a society in which
rape is either encouraged or tolerated I
believe that that's not true I don't
live in a country is that that's the
definition encouraged or tolerated
I definitely wouldn't say encouraged to
an extent tolerated yes I would have to
disagree that also how was rape
tolerated in the United States um we do
a lot of victim blaming we don't hold
people accountable we don't really trust
the women I mean you look at the
Cavanaugh hearing all the Republicans
they kind of believe her but they really
don't care question yeah define the
victim blaming would be not fully
believing the woman accuser and striking
her down and saying oh well maybe you
got too drunk at the party maybe you're
lying about this that's victim for you I
want to make this clear because it might
be a fundamental disagreement yeah for
you is victim a synonym with accuser or
do you mean victim being someone who's
actually in the conference I mean I
would say it cause we're gonna sit in
having but you think victim isn't a
synonym for accuser well I mean if
you're the victim and then you accuse
your
your rapist or sexual assault or doing I
guess yeah how do you know they're a
victim that's what they're saying I
usually believe the woman until proven
the other way really yeah did you
believe that's how we should base our
laws and it makes it an accusation not
our laws but we should we should believe
her for the most part she had a good
testimony if you looked at the testimony
who was the one that looked believable
cause it sure as [ __ ] wasn't Kavanaugh
yeah I just breathe and I can't man and
she was cool calm and collect that whole
time Kavanaugh was screaming and ripping
heads off he was crying oh yeah I know
crying and I think more important is the
evidence what was your name again
Nick Nick what year are you here it's
awful
are you the one who did I'm not naked
paper that was you that was you I read
about you okay what okay where's your
evidence that that was me I'm saying
evidence still matters you have to have
evidence as you said you tend to in the
absence of evidence with Christine you
see I didn't say I didn't say absence of
evidence I doubt you understand the
point yeah I know I didn't say absence
of evidence so with Christine for
there's a complete absence of evidence
but you said you were sorry please
there's not a complete we know there was
a party that night
we know Kavanaugh was there we know she
was there she had vivid recounts lately
whatever night they're talking about in
the news from DC metro area she was
remember tonight okay well they it was
in the DC metro area brass who was there
Brett Kavanaugh mark judge yeah has
anyone else corroborated this yes no no
there was actually there was actually
there was actually another woman who who
said yes Brett Kavanaugh mark judge and
Christine buzzing forward we're at of
the alleged party that they were talking
the First Minister she brought forward
an item so let me let me get back to
something like home you do set down
you did say believe the woman until
otherwise she makes the accusation John
that's what you said yeah do you not see
how incredibly dangerous that what if
someone called a lady sorry
these aren't criminal proceedings right
now I'm talking about like no Cavanaugh
so you believe in the court of public
opinion believe the woman who accuses no
matter what not no matter what with this
what you said I didn't say you said you
believed the woman until proven
otherwise in other words you need to
disprove the claim frame yeah that's
incredibly dangerous and it's not
founded in reality especially
considering at the incredibly Louis we
had we had look at look at the look at
the catalog we had there's a reason that
it's innocent till proven guilty in
association that's so for us to not
apply here just because of rape would be
incredibly after and again this is what
perpetuates the idea of rape culture you
say I believe the victim oh you know
they're the victim
I believe survivor
to determine that toilet browse as you
suggested just to believe a woman until
proven otherwise I think I might have I
think I might have misspoke so okay but
I'm saying we shouldn't you know right
right right after these allegations came
out so I was kind of in the middle I
didn't know you know there wasn't a lot
of evidence for her or for him it wasn't
looking great for him and a lot of new
evidence there's is some evidence
there's a lot a lot of Republicans just
jump to oh no this is nothing this is
nothing she's lying she's lying without
knowing anything so why why are her
claims automatically invalidated like
it's the same on the flip side no
Republicans the data validated
I know but landish claims need to be
though but no I don't know what really
wanted to look into them even when they
came out discussing yeah okay that's
incorrect people have looked into people
they didn't they didn't want they tried
to find witnesses they couldn't no they
didn't try to find witnesses some other
people want to come forward so I'm just
going to disagree with you okay if you
believe believe the woman interpret all
that stuff let's talk about rape culture
a little bit literally it all right I'm
not gonna be with you on that point
eight your position all right just
remember one last time let me get the
last gonna be an insult it's not you
mean it's not a minute so I don't like
insulting people or politics I'm not I'm
just gonna say don't you know rape
culture is a real thing it's you know it
is a big problem I know many people
whose friends have been raped and
sexually assaulted it really triggers a
lot of people like don't don't just come
out here and try to stay the father
I don't think no no we've been good but
I saw the last video last time you hear
and it got a little heated I'll you know
I've just said it was a guy who got very
yeah what the overwhelming majority of
yeah series our conversations like this
I know I think it's important to
disagree no I know it is and that's why
I think it's important for their also
did have the rule of law respected when
it comes to rape for the same reason
because I would want you to be afforded
the same benefit
I don't innocent until proven guilty I'm
not guilty of coming here to try and
stir the pot we have that we've had
these cameras rang the whole time yeah
so I my point is you might have an
impression that's not entirely accurate
and that often occurs in any situation
I doubt but sexual assault and rape
culture is the real thing it's a real
problem you look at all this stuff
that's been coming out over the past few
years with the me to movement it's a
real thing it's going down I'm taking
the time thank you there are plenty more
conversations to get to hear but I just
wanted to let you know that none of
these episodes occur without you joining
mug club as they're often demonetized
before you can say what jiske so join up
at lateral credit coms flash mug club
not only to get access to the full one
hour show daily that's not available on
youtube but you also get access to all
of CR TV's lineup including Gavin
McGuinness Mark Levin not to mention
this wonderful hand etched hand-painted
mug you can try it for free for seven
days today and it's the only way that
we're able to keep this kind of content
alive now if you can't afford mug club
please bookmark this channel and check
back for videos every day is sometimes
the subscription fee doesn't work so of
course hit the notification bell here
follow me on instagram at loud or
threader light or better not come slash
month club thanks so much for the
support we need you on with the show a
position on a topic discussed quite a
bit I believe the idea that rape culture
I just want to make sure I define as
defined sort of by on by academia
and modern feminist early feminists and
gender studies the idea that we live in
a culture that encourages perpetuates or
tolerates rape systemically I don't
think that's incorrect
if you disagree with me no I definitely
think that I don't think in this country
I don't think that rapes rape is
encouraged in this country I don't think
it's encouraged I think sometimes it can
be tolerated sometimes it can be pushed
under the rug but as far as encouraging
it we're not over here saying hey let's
go out and bring all these people that's
not right as far as tolerating I think
tolerating is a sorry it's an
interesting word to use because I think
tolerating means you're being okay with
it right and so I don't I don't think
that we as a country are okay with rape
I think that we I mean it's horrible
like you said I heard earlier said we
want to castrate all rapists yes I think
in the country we obviously think rape
is horrible crime and we prosecute
rapists
no we do yes I think I just wanted to
clarify to hear what your stand is
because it's hard to hear and I think if
there's a penny people yelling at you
and I just wanna hear what you had to
say and like what years I just agree
with that that that premise that we live
in a rape I just free to act I agree I
disagree that that's the country that we
live and I don't think that is I just
wanted to hear it was it mark Marley
mark Marley's I didn't hear your name
Marley okay well I knew those two
minutes wanna hear what you had to say
thank very much more yeah I know it's
horrible
yeah like shout down I think that you at
least if there's a voice and you'll be
Caesar to come here and say what you
want to say and
we already raping a horrible crime oh
it's my mean I have friends and might me
personally have dealt with sexual
assault and I think it's horrible but as
far as encouraging it we're not teaching
young men and women oh go out and so I
think you're coming to work on our
country our campus thank you so much
[Music]
okay what was your name sir
Brandi grant nice to meet you grant with
you yeah I don't know you're an Steven
steed Steven nice to meet you grant so
um I assume then you're not familiar at
all with a segment and basically this is
where we have hopefully rational
discussions we rationalize their own
positions on what are considered
controversial issues rape cults want to
make sure them really clear about
defining rape culture I would use the
definition that would be taught here
probably on your college campus in
gender studies or with modern feminist
theory or as it's been used in sort of
societal nomenclature the idea that we
live in a culture that perpetuates
encourages or even tolerates rape rape
culture not a thing
disagree if you do you can your mobile
to change my mind so the claim the claim
isn't my largest concern it's that you
uh you're here saying I'm here to start
a productive discourse right that's your
goal what's what's your mission
statement tell me that well if you just
would like for you to rationalize your
position I see on campus a lot a lot of
people we've had a lot of people come up
in spring we've had some very productive
discussions you can rationalize your
position and I can rationalize mine I
think especially when we have a media
obviously that leans a certain political
direction that it's been accepted among
societal nomenclature it's important
with a different point of view rape
culture is not a thing that's fair so my
beef with it is the so the aggressive
ignorance I'm not saying you're
aggressive obviously not I'm sorry
however right now I'm standing right
back there
there and I'm talking to everyone around
no we can hear you yeah you're not
starting the dialogue you're trying to
start actually okay so I'm sad a lot
between me and you you know we're having
a dialogue okay
and then millions of people will see the
dialogue okay and then they can judge
for themselves who's who's rationalised
their position this is not meant to be
an argument it's gotten hostile
sometimes because people come in and sit
you know scream we get really upset but
ya know it's we so not everyone here can
necessarily hear us so there's a lot of
people that are in a way entering a
one-sided dialogue and here's how the
sign says rape culture isn't real right
not everyone's going to get up here to
talk to you not everyone's gonna feel
comfortable doing that especially if
they have been sexually assaulted that's
not something a lot of people like to
talk about um but also so we see the
sign and then you're stuck thinking
about it all day that some people
believe that some horrible thing that
may have happened to you and the culture
that protects perpetrators doesn't exist
so - - even things the rape horn a
horrible heinous crime don't support it
at all I understand goes through the day
thinking that that would be incorrect
but the idea that a society supports the
perpetrators yes that's okay I'm okay
with some one thing okay yes I I want to
separate the two because we kind of
blended them there okay appreciate
supporting the or or even not
stigmatizing those that act or punishing
them enough or frequently but what I'm
saying is I see people walking around I
see girls in tears and that's because of
your sign because they're seeing that
belief presented and not having the
chance or the comfort there's you know
look there's two microphones here
there's a camera in my face you have
your little book of facts I don't have
anything prepared that's true I just
went I'm not I'm not referencing this
right now I have it for you if you would
like to it I've seen you know I'm really
I'm not interested in the discourse
about rape culture I'm more interested
in jasmine I'm upset with the mode
the discourse is taking place and I
wanted to voice that concern okay first
off how would you have the discourse
take place not in a crowd of a bunch of
people that can't hear me yeah yes is
going to take place again people why do
you I have a yeah you see the whole
point is that the reason for this is the
OP and the reason this is important to
have someone who's worked in cable news
for years you know I appeared on Fox CNN
BBC and couldn't stand the sound bite
sort of system of news this is the
opposite of that completely unedited
allowing people to rationalize their
positions long form and of course it's
very hard for a conservative to get a
permit on campus to conduct these
debates it's often very hard to find
people who will who will do so and
usually end up with either an activist
or professor the goal to this discourse
is to have conversations with real
people about these topics well don't you
think it's kind of like setting yourself
up we don't women just own students
that's all I've seen what today we're
doing at this campus yeah we do pretty
eclectic mix last time we did it in
front of the White House are the people
do you ever like debate debate someone
we're sure it's very hard to often find
a leftist opponents for who are willing
to engage in a debate it's increasingly
difficult why do you think that is I I
couldn't tell you I think a lot of the
reason is because these concepts of
writing why do you think it is well I
think that the concepts I'm arguing for
so rape culture and things like you add
your mail or white privilege design last
time those are really really complicated
concepts and it's not so simple as
saying oh that person's white I'm gonna
pay them more there is structural things
going on and lots of us are just
bystanders that it's being perpetuated
through our day-to-day operations so
there's not the oppressors and the
oppressed what's being perpetuated
oppression Mike so there's there's a I
read an article in a philosophy class it
was five forms of oppression on so say a
group is marginalized like the elderly
often have a hard time finding work sure
and maybe there's medical reasons for
that but then that's hi is into ableism
and that's a different I know this is
tangential but
um my whole point is you're gonna have
trouble finding people to fit you
because these concepts are very hard to
articulate if you're going in with the
mindset of just changed my mind it's
really hard to want to engage in that
discourse like okay how about this how
about let me said let me use your
standard articulated my standard yeah
don't even change my mind articulate it
it isn't it wonderful to say all of
these positions that you hold are so
nuanced you couldn't possibly be burned
with articulating it but I am so you
think you're the minority do I think I'm
the minority on a call that's why we're
on a college campus yeah not written out
here you see many people who have been
other who have more right leading
viewpoints who would disagree with
yourself who have to be quiet about
their points of view but you said that
all these issues like white privilege
for example like rape culture they're so
nuanced your position was that it's hard
to find leftists or progressives or
liberals whatever term you want to use
would be willing to debate because
they're so nuanced that they wouldn't be
able to articulate their position isn't
that convenient is it convenient no
that's why we can't change your mind
because you can't articulate your
position no because you have to read the
hundreds of books and articles that the
professors who are able to articulate a
read I can articulate it I'm a junior
I'm an acting major I'm not well-versed
in any of it sure and I'm here talking
to you just cuz I felt that your your
approach changed my mind perhaps maybe I
find it maybe I don't think you want to
change your mind
well the idea are you familiar with a
Socratic method is it like a Socratic
seminar like in high school yeah that's
what they would often do so they're
crowded seminars you know but you're
familiar with what it is yes okay so
it's basically rationalizing one's
position yes that's what this is about
and you and you know how they often
don't teach the Socratic method in
college now and right now especially
with the with the Cavanaugh hearings
going on rape culture let me ask you
this how would you define rape culture
maybe that's where we're disagreeing I
think I tonight I'm gonna use a little
thought exercise go ahead I guess
visualizations
I I jog you can probably tell hi Jim how
could I tell I mean you look fit I don't
know John John you'll see you'll look
you're fit okay done I jog and I jog at
night I jog anywhere I want
mm-hmm I can go anywhere I want I feel
safe yeah
winning pin sure so whether or not I
someone was saying you had some
statistics about that yeah whether or
not the statistics are true the
widespread belief in the fear is real
it's it's a part of arc you're sharing
elective because women know whoa whoa
whoa I was going to agree with you there
until you why do you where do you think
I just disagreed with you what do you
mean you just spoke and I was actually
about to agree with you about obviously
you you feel more safe than women who
jog but then I dent and I was going to
agree with you but then you said when
this is a thought it was your thought
exercise where do you think I hopped off
the train that's an example of rape
culture you then use that to say it's an
example of a set of our cultural beliefs
what cultural belief makes a woman
uncomfortable at night perhaps the
everyone should be uncomfortable jogging
at night you should it's very unsafe I
hope you wear reflectors I do I hope you
have a buddy system I hope you have your
Find My Phone app on hopefully I don't
know if you're allowed to carry on this
game mr. Jones can never feel that fear
it's if you're just the way I'm
socialized and we can talk about
socialization at length I sure but I'm
if you are I've been socialized to not
fear those situations and so I don't and
women whether or not are you familiar
with the concept of an a leaf I would
love you for you explain it it's a
philosophical concept so basically you
can believe something so I know if I'm
on the Skywalk at the Grand Canyon
I believe I'm safe I know it's not gonna
fall but I have a little a leaf it's
like a sub little thing that you can't
control that sound it makes me shake
right so it could be you could relate it
to the concept of
women believe that they are equally safe
or unsafe the men but the a leap is
still there that they're not or that
that could be a target because of their
sex yeah and they could be yeah I'm not
denying that okay but again the idea
that that doesn't mean that we tolerate
or encourage rape culture the idea
that's as a society yeah my definition
is not if your definition is a woman
feels less comfortable alone at night
because she's weaker than a man then I
would agree with you but that's not an
example of no no it's not the point is
you presented the anecdotal I'm talking
about the empirical the analytical and
that's important that matters see okay
so how would you how would you change it
for example so you're talking about
women who feel afraid right I believe in
I change an entire culture yes because
you believe we have a rape culture how
would you change it what do we do wrong
how do we encourage rape how do we how
do we tolerate right we don't encourage
rape I don't I think we tolerate it by
not punishing in and up we're often by
on but we do punish it
we do plenty of [ __ ] we prosecute we
charge rapist we put them in prison but
at the same rate as many other crimes
and armed robberies arson assault
they're convicted at the same rate we
don't tolerate rape we prosecute and put
them in prison the worst
maximum-security prisons all right so
I'm curious if sexual assault is
included in your umbrella
no not for rape we can separate we can
discuss the two issues separately if
that would be the dispute but let's
let's talk about sexual assault culture
okay
well because you came down he said
aggressive ignorance I would assumed you
had some specific details with which you
would disagree what if you're not
prepared a sign is generally not a good
idea it's not myself
oh really who sign is it I just heard a
vote oh there are people running a voter
registrations so who wrote this I did so
what's your sign
sure but you you're using an emblem that
I'm prepared what I know I so know I'm
using I'm using it as an emblem for
shocking unpreparedness because I didn't
prepare for this so if you're not
prepared
I wouldn't put up a sign you said you
want to sit down that I am aggressively
ignorant you how to sign and then you
say what I'm not prepared for this
that's not how this works it's also not
our words that you can send this one-way
message and just say rape culture isn't
real
that is exactly because you can sit down
and discuss it no it's not I'm not
insulting anybody and I am prepared your
us listen if you were really trying to
start a productive dialogue and not get
abused for your YouTube page you
wouldn't do it this way that's all I
wanted to how what I do is not this way
you how would I people that are
qualified or maybe prepare a lecture
like if you think that you say you come
to college campuses you think most of us
are liberal and become a professor man
so you believe only professors should be
allowed to share empirical data well
this isn't a one-way dialogue you've
been allowed to express your opinion
tirely I haven't yelled at you you've so
you created a sign insulting me you just
don't have any signage made my friends
crying so I mean that's emotional you
said your factual matter offended
no I it offends me as somebody who
prepares I'm not seeing this going
anywhere productive
what evidence do you have that we live
in a rape culture that's like I said my
purpose for coming up here didn't have
to do with that because I'm not gonna be
able to argue late it or argue late
argue that's okay I'm not doing the
gotcha what's that it's we both have dry
mouth and it's don't work that's not
what I'm doing I'm not gonna be able to
articulate it I don't have any facts I
don't have figures I don't have anything
I know you haven't presented any either
that's not to me because you've said
that it's too nuanced to get into that
you don't seem to want to get into the
realm with facts would you like to I
don't like I said would you like to get
in the realm of facts and oh people
don't care about that okay well then
don't accuse me of not bringing up facts
you've said you're not interested I
apologize you said let me let me just
say one thing okay really quickly cuz I
know you have to go so let me wrap this
up for you you presented this with an
insulting sign
you were completely ill-prepared you
said that all of your views are so
nuanced that you couldn't possibly be
expected to articulate them that's not
what I said
or liberals are any ones that you
couldn't possibly particularly to
expected to articulate them and then you
said I didn't bring any facts and when I
said are you interested in hearing them
you said no listen I don't think this is
going to be very productive just had a
very productive discussion with several
other people that you are not among
people aren't gonna want to debate
because your mentality has changed my
mind
I want you to come to me bring me
something to change my mind yes that's
not the mentality that is going to be
helpful director dialogue if I made a
sign that said rape culture is real
change my mind I don't know I wouldn't
because I don't care for that kind of
style I guess so I pointless many people
here do okay my point I I really didn't
want to talk about great poetry I'm yeah
I'm not prepared I don't know what to
say about it I don't know how to
articulate that I think it's an issue I
don't even know how to tell you how I
came to think it's an issue
okay so just something I learned along
the way but I'm trying to tell you that
I don't think what you're doing is a
productive way to even you said you
wanted to
you didn't say reify what was your
rationalization unless you want to
rationalize your position I just don't
think this is a good way to do that
that's my main point it doesn't matter
if I were paired or not it's about the
mode of displace sure can I ask you one
more thing would you be willing to give
someone here your info find it a
professor any professor here on campus
and help organize some kind of a debate
or conversation no no I mean just
literally give your email we can follow
up you know to someone one of these
people working here working the camera
we can he can grab your email write it
down any professor you pick and you know
or set up a dialog how you think it
would be best or most fair well listen
we'll get your info you don't have to do
anything just an email and anything that
you think really just give him your
email to write it down I was because you
had to sign so just give me your email I
know I was supposed to take it back at
12:30 okay yeah just give him give him
your email and any way that you any way
you think this could cut conversation
could be conducted more productively
we'll send you an email and you can send
us back your thoughts what you'd like to
do and we'll make it happen one of these
other videos or I would usually say
subscriber hits a notification bell but
YouTube doesn't even notify you anymore
so your only option now is to sign up
for the daily show the full hour daily
show at laterals Crider comm slash mug
club join mug club and help us continue
the content we're able to do it were
able to do it relatively inexpensively
with with you know the help of
Bangladeshi children the problem we have
with their good at web development but
not so much with writing the jokes
not an intelligence factor but it's too
much inside baseball cultural
differences so we can up the game if you
join